When you know enough about your data, you
can help your machine connect the dots with
supervised learning. In supervised learning,
you show the machine the connection between
different variables and known outcomes. In machine
learning, this is called the supervised learning.
It's called supervised learning because it's
already tagged with identifying information.
Imagine you wanted to train a machine to help you
predict how long it will take you to drive home.
You would start by creating a set of labeled
data. This data would include weather conditions,
time of day, and whether it's a holiday.
These are your inputs. The output would be
the amount of time it took to drive home on that
particular day. In this case, your independent
variables would be the input and your dependent
variable would be the output. Here you want to use
different machine learning algorithms to map the
relationships between these different variables.
You can use statistical regression for this
and determine how the independent variables
affect the dependent variable. You intuitively
know that if it's raining outside, it will take
you longer to drive home, but machines have to
rely on data and statistics. They have to look
at the length of your commute and compare
it to labeled data it has on the weather.
Let's see how we can create a supervised
machine learning model to help
us determine our commute time.
The first thing you want to
do is create a training set.
Based on this training set, your machine might see
there's a direct relationship between the amount
of rain and the time it takes to get home. The
more it rains, the longer you'll be on the road.
It might also see there's a connection between
the time you leave work and the time you'll be
on the road. The closer you are to 5 p.m.,
the longer it takes for you to get home.
Your machine finds some of the relationships
with your labeled data. This is the start of
your data model. It begins to understand concepts
like how rain impacts the way people drive.
It also starts to see that there are more
people who travel during certain times of day.
Then your machine takes this training set
and applies it to a test set of your data.
It looks to see if the model in this training set
holds true when you're looking at many more days.
You could ask the computer to predict how
long it will take you to drive home each day
and then give it feedback on how
accurate it was in its prediction.
Over time, the machine will learn and adapt its
model to improve the output. Your machine will
continue to tune the model in the training set and
you can make adjustments based on the new data.
This is pretty similar to how humans
learn. Think about when you learned
how to drive. You started in a small
parking lot with an adult guiding you.
Then you got to the point where you could drive
predictably and safely in this smaller space.
Then once you built up enough confidence,
you'd head out into the open road.
You won't learn everything you need to know about
driving in the parking lot but you should get
enough data to help you get started. Chances
are you'll still learn a lot of new skills,
and hopefully you'll continue to improve
over time until you become an expert driver.
The key thing to remember is that in supervised
machine learning you know a lot more about the
training data. You can feed labeled data
into the machine that's easily classified.
So, with your commute home you know more about the
weather, holidays, and time of day. This labeled
data is the key difference between supervised
learning and other forms of machine learning.